[موسيقى]
قبل سنوات أجنبية ، كانت هذه قرية ساحلية
اليوم وهي عاصمة
ثاني أكبر اقتصاد في دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي
والعاصمة الأربعين في العالم اعتبارًا من عام 2021 الثروة النفطية ،
وكلاهما من أبوظبي ، تعد الإمارات العربية المتحدة
واحدة من أكبر 10 منتجين  النفط
والغاز وأكثر من 95 في المائة منه يكمن
هنا ، ولا يزال ثلث الناتج المحلي الإجمالي لدولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة
يعتمد على بيع
الهيدروكربونات لكن الحكومة تريد
تغيير ذلك وإسراع رئيس الدولة الجديد
الشيخ محمد بن زايد
النيان الذي تولى منصبه.  بعد وفاة شقيقه الأكبر
خليفة في مايو 2022 ،
يريد تنويع الاقتصاد ليشمل مجالات جديدة
بما في ذلك المعرفة والابتكار التكنولوجي
هو مفتاح المنافسة التي
تعتقد الحكومة أن الخطة تتبلور هنا
في أبو ظبي حيث
افتتحت جامعة أبحاث عليا تركز على الذكاء الاصطناعي اثنين
منذ سنوات ، سميت على اسم
رئيس الدولة محمد بن زايد ،
تضم جامعة الذكاء الاصطناعي حوالي
250 طالبًا وهي تقدم
درجات الماجستير والدكتوراه لمدة عامين في المجالات.  مثل التعلم الآلي الذي
يبحث عن طرق جديدة لاستخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي في الطب ، نحاول مساعدة
الأطباء ليس فقط في رؤية
الواقع الافتراضي ما يقومون ببنائه
ولكن أيضًا ليشعروا بلمسه بالجهاز اللمسي الذي
يمكننا وضعه فوقه
ثم المجالات  من ردود الفعل القوية التي تريد
تجربتها ، هذا أمر لا يصدق ، نعم إنه في
الواقع يخلق مقاومة يمكنني
الشعور بمقاومة الجلد
وتطوير بشر افتراضي يمكنهم
المشاركة في محادثة ، وهذا في الواقع
غير خاضع للإشراف بالكامل ، لذا فهي
تتعلم أساسًا من الكثير من البيانات من
الإنترنت  هل أنت قلق من أن
الاقتصاد ليس له وجبة غداء مجانية ، سيكون أمرًا
رائعًا إذا تمكنا من العثور على
مصدر طاقة بديل هذا العام حدثًا مهمًا
، حيث يقدم حفل التخرج الأول للجامعة
جيلًا جديدًا من خبراء الذكاء الاصطناعي محليًا في
أبو ظبي والذي لا يقل أهمية عن
اقتصاد دولة الإمارات العربية المتحدة  لأن المدرسة
تعتقد أن الذكاء الاصطناعي يمكن أن يساهم بما يصل إلى
320 مليار دولار في اقتصاد المنطقة
بحلول عام 2030. تي  يعرف الرجل المسؤول هنا
بالتأكيد شيئًا أو شيئين عن الذكاء الاصطناعي ،
فهو أستاذ في علوم الكمبيوتر
والتعلم الآلي قام بتدريسه في سانفورد
كارنيجي ميلون وحتى Facebook ، دعنا
نذهب للقاء أول رئيس للجامعة ،
إريك شينغ ،
سيكون الذكاء الاصطناعي تقنية
أساسية تؤثر على الجميع  مناطق في الاقتصاد إما
بشكل غير مباشر أو بشكل مباشر ، فهذا يحدث
بالفعل وأنت تعلم أنها تجربة حديثة ،
فهي قيد التنفيذ بالفعل إذا
أغلقت فجأة جميع خدمات الذكاء الاصطناعي في الوقت الحالي ،
فلن يتمكن الناس من العيش بشكل مريح للغاية ،
على سبيل المثال ، أعطني
مثالاً على ذلك  على سبيل المثال ، سوف تفقد
محرك البحث الخاص بك
، لا يمكنني أخذ ذلك بعيدًا عني ، إريك
إذا نظرت إلى وادي السيليكون الصحيح
وادي السيليكون ، أه أنت تعرف نتيجة رئيسية
أه من مساهمة جامعة رئيسية
هناك جامعة ستانفورد
التي هي أكثر من جامعة  إنها
مركز للابتكار ، ما نحاول
تحقيقه هنا كجامعة هو
إحداث تأثير مماثل نريد
تحويل هذه المنطقة إلى
معرفة  نوع dge-centric
للاقتصاد الجديد والمجتمع الجديد والجامعة
أصبحا حجر الزاوية لمثل هذا المشروع